puis 6
c'est pas comme si vous êtes libre de
faire qu'est ce que tu peux conduire à
noter les photos boukhdhir savez grasset
d'achille et marraine a fait a eu sur
l'autre c'est notre match et celle dames
la tableau de robes reconnaît maintenant
mr l omerta brassaud où il a dit qu'il
faut jamais at on en a
regardez contente d'être ici mais je
pense peut-être le plus grand défi va
être plus haut niveau social
le fait que ce soit une personne timide
ça va être différent d'un autre élève
mais je vois que de se faire des amis
québécois ça va peut-être être plus
difficile étant donné la culture qui est
différent on essaie de créer un climat
de accueillant chaleureux
les élèves dans la classe c'est comme
une famille qui aussi c'est ton ami elle
même fille 19 ans et star
cela est ce qu'on prend les deux c'est
voici un chien en trop c'est ici on est
en sécurité et il n'y a pas de problème
du palet d'or puis un repas c'est pas
dangereux pour ta vie cesser leur faire
comprendre que ici c'est pas dangereux
puis quand ils comprennent sommet où
sont heureux ça leur en prend pas
beaucoup
oui je les aime beaucoup
ouais bon dîner
anissa du laboratoire ben berden où la
jeune noir et doré je renouvelle comme
moi je suis très fier d'eux ils le
savent et je leur dis que ton est
parfois aberrants un invisible c'est
vrai ils veulent se prendre en main puis
bon on leur dit de toute façon comme
rugueux milieu d'un athlète aveugle
envers lui et nous aussi on t'aime on
leur dit souvent on n'est pas là pour
vous servir la nourriture sur un plateau
mais on va vous apprendre à pêcher comme
dirait l'autre
tranquillement
pour nous c'est important
les gens voient que ces réfugiés là font
l'effort nécessaire
je dirais pas seulement d'intégration
mais de contribuer plus tôt au
développement économique et social de
notre région si la société ne démontre
pas un signe d'ouverture ne s'implique
pas elle même pour moi c'est un échec
le gros bout du bâton demain quand même
dans la main des personnes qui arrivent
il ya une volonté de faut donner comme
on dit en bon québécois sont 110 % pour
apprendre le français pourrait aider
poussé ses enfants est aussi un point
c'est que les parents se rendent compte
de leur responsabilité envers leurs
oh
cap sur la belgique de f1 en général je
voudrais ici des gens quand même que je
le courage déjà avec une grande force
une résilience donc ils sont arrivés
jusqu'ici ils ont quand même accepté de
venir n'ont voulu avoir un meilleur
futur pour lui les enfants la sécurité
tant le plus grand choc que tout le
monde ramène le juste sentir qu'ils sont
en sécurité
c'est un énorme atout puis que le stress
le niveau de stress diminue par contre
au niveau de l'adaptation d'enfler
symptômes plus de 1 sony
à l'anxiété du futur l'anxiété de savoir
que simon est capable d'apprendre la
langue ne pas être capable de
communiquer ne pas savoir comment
prendre le métro seront d'un endroit à
l'autre
c'est une grande source passé et c'est
elle qui aime c'est elle qui aime la
balançoire alors elle est heureuse de
voir sentir sans fils en scène parce que
quand elle était jeune et l'on faisait
l'adorent belgique est un des éditeurs
électrique belco l'un des must have en
charles lightoller
le magic leur label qu'elle cherche un
bras sa fille fait à ternir en abandonne
une tour atx ou femelle marron ou nana
trémoulinas emparé à manama à mal et n'a
marqué une sharon utaka d'omar khadr qui
tournait
et
vaud